okay let's get to matt and aggie chicago
bears titans they had just gotten beat
by the bangles you know they're going to
be ticked unfortunately for the bears
they're the next game on the schedule
guess what happened here's matt nagy
after the loss
yeah i do i do and and uh you know it's
that's a good that's a good thing and i
did feel early on that um you know we
had a couple of those drives where it
wasn't so much the penalties on the
front end jj it was more of the three
and outs you know we just we weren't
getting first downs and uh that's what
felt like it on the front end and then
you know you get to a point there at the
end of the half where uh you get a
couple completions and then you're just
going backwards instead of going forward
you know and when you have that and then
the rest of the game there's just some
some stuff that went on
uh that it just makes it hard and we're
not in a position right now offensively
to make things hard that's just a simple
fact we need we need to do everything we
can to stay ahead of the sticks so that
we can play football and and you know
get the run game going and get the quick
game going and when you pick and choose
to take a shot
you got to protect so that you can hit
that shot you know what i'm saying so
that that's kind of how this thing goes
in the simplest way that i could ask it
are the chicago bears as good as the
record or is this foal's gold across the
board
no i mean they're overrated we all know
that um the biggest problem he said if
we can protect that means they they
haven't had protection on that offensive
line and when you had mitchell trubisky
he could move around he could avoid some
things and buy some time you don't have
that luxury
um with nick foles because he's a big
stiff and that offensive line they can't
run the football he talks about getting
behind or ahead of the chains well you
have to have success on first down
whether it's a quick pass and whether
it's running for four or five yards now
you have a second and manageable second
and five second and six but they're not
getting those type of positive plays and
then you look up for the chicago bears
offense it's third down and ten it's
third down and twelve it's third down
and fifteen and i don't care who you
have at quarterback it's gonna be very
difficult to pick up those long down the
distances so
that's a failure on the chicago bears
part not getting off into line you you
need offensive line to protect they
should have known that last year it's
like i mean what are they doing in the
front office that's that's the thing
that's very puzzling to me
what's that like as a player when you
hear the coach say we just we can't
screw up at all like when you when you
when your coach is saying there's zero
room for air uh is it do you lose any
trust like is there any moments where a
coach goes to a press conference and it
directly affects the locker room does
that happen every week or is that rare
when a coach goes to a press conference
in general how does that bounce back to
the team
well i just you know i don't mind having
a coach be completely honest you know
what i mean like if i need to play
better and i'm a leader of that defense
he can call me out that doesn't bother
me it motivates me a lot of guys get
sensitive when you when a coach calls
them out a lot of guys get sensitive
when when a coach calls them out but to
me it really doesn't bother me because
if i'm doing my job if i'm earning my
paycheck then the coach will never call
me out in in front of any media or
anything like that and i don't have to
take it personally but you just you just
want your coach to protect you but at
the same time be honest with you so i
don't know how you take that
um but that's just the way it is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports